and Rob stone joins us from Russia
stoner how are you
that's former PA I actually emailed you
a couple of months ago to say how proud
I was of you then I didn't hear back and
I went man I did something you're very
you're your kind of spam worthy ban if
you emailed me damn straight you would
have gotten a response within a second
so we're sideways okay
God's honest truth I reached out to
charissa Thompson and I said can you
give me Rob stones email address and I
sent you an email that moment you were
hosting college football and I wanted to
let you know how proud I was because how
many years do we go back 20 20 years ago
you were a production assistant early
it's funny early it's probably 91 92 is
when I first got to work with you and to
this day and to this day I remember one
of the baseball highlights that I cut
for you and we would have these
post-production meetings at the end of
SportsCenter and it was kind of it was a
tenth time between the the working
stiffs and the talent at that time I
think you guys have gotten some some bad
shot sheets some handwritten garbage
that you guys weren't happy with I think
it was doing over there and it didn't
immediate you just stood up and like
threw this highlight and it was I'm
pretty sure it was met and read and I
put my hand up and I mean I'm telling
you a little pee came out when I put my
hand up and he said this is exactly what
I want and I mean it was fear sheer
excitement and I remember the highlight
to the day Dan there was a one nothing
game and all I did was go through the
entire at bat of the game-winning RBI
and I matched it with somebody in the
dugout chewing gum so they put the gum
in the mouth and the Yap bastard and
fouling off and fouling off the gum
starting to get tired
boom quarter foul balls or foul balls
fine
he gets the hit the warning run throws
the gum out that's your highlight it's
done to this day God's honest truth I
remember this is one of my PA Sports
Center highlights Thank You Rob that's
all we wanted to talk about we didn't
want to talk about the World Cup
how would you give us an idea about what
it's like when you're not working in
Russia
how's the house the fan base the food
etc yeah it's a there's not a whole lot
that I'm not working so now that the
tournament it's in the later stages
there are a few pockets of down time and
in the early days before the families
arrived it was pretty much Alexi Lalas
and I and whoever wanted to hang out
with us and we might do like a minor
excursion we would go to a Russian banya
which is a basically a Russian bathhouse
and sweaty Russian bed and towels would
beat us with birch twig in a sauna so
that was that was a highlight you know
searching searching for food that you
can recognize on the menu nodding
quickly to anything involving vodka you
know eventually when you're away from
home for a while you're just like can I
get a taco I would love is there a
bonito around here I understand your
borscht I understand that this this
animal is treated as a food in your
world but not mine I just I just need a
little America but otherwise man this
tournament has been fantastic you know
I've I've been fortunate to cover Men's
World Cup started in 1998 and every four
years
I really feel they grow in magnitude not
just internationally but clearly
domestically as well and there was all
this fear Dan that nobody back home
would really care about this World Cup
because the US Men's National Team
wasn't involved in it for the first time
since back to 1986 and I just I laughed
I said that there's no way that is the
case people America loves a good
tournament they've completely embraced
the World Cup and I knew that this is
going to be one of those seminal moments
where the numbers were going to back it
up where people are watching people are
caring about it
they're absolutely involved in it
they're caught up in the intrigue and
the drama and in my book I've been
saying this for a couple weeks now this
is going down as the greatest World Cup
I think beyond just our generation
but ever with the storylines that have
played out and the fact that we as an
American audience aren't held to how the
US is doing we are Clinton just sitting
back almost as in neutral and taking in
all these storylines without feeling
this absolute pain and anger and disgust
we can just watch the game with the
clear head take it all in and absolutely
enjoy what's been a magical month how
are the English fans sad despondent
hungover right now would be my guess you
know it was interesting coming into this
tournament not a whole lot was made
about this English national team
they weren't sexy there wasn't that kind
of iconic type star there wasn't this
build-up there wasn't this antagonistic
relationship with the media which so
happens we're so often happens back
there and they weren't allowed to come
here and smile and laugh and have fun
and be young and they started achieving
this success early and you could use the
momentum back home about hey this team
isn't that bad but they still weren't
coming here you know clearly there's a
history between English supporters and
maybe the Russian fan base and not a
good history so I think English fans
were hesitant tentative to make their
way here but once they started getting
that momentum and they got out of the
group you would you were seeing more and
more fans you're hearing that accent you
are hearing the scenes that the songs
and the singing throughout Moscow
throughout Red Square now you know the
fact that they lost I think they lost
with great pride and I feel like they
have and this is talking to our English
friends that we work with that they've
kind of unified this country you know
there's this team getting knocked out
the semifinals has brought so many
people closer together and they're
giving him this hope and this belief
we're in the past I think it was always
a little bit more negative and now it's
clearly enough the positive vibes around
England net soccer team is Rob stone Fox
Sports lead studio host the FIFA World
Cup today how big of a upset would it be
if Croatia wins this on Sunday
I think a pretty sizable upset collation
comes in ranked 20th in the world and
look the FIFA World Rankings are skewed
and they're they're odd and I don't know
whose abacus is they use to make it up
but in the end you look at this France
makeup and you're saying wow these guys
are current stars and these are stars in
the making these are guys who who are
scratching the surface of having that
Pele type conversation put around them
so I think it would be a sizable upset
only because of that but would you look
at what Croatia has yeah I'm trying to
find what that parallel is for these two
American sports and I don't know what it
is because it you know a kind of Green
Bay Packer but without Aaron Rodgers um
you know it's Patriots but just making
savvy moves and strength up the middle
and deep everywhere and no places their
weakness was gonna be hurt this Croatian
team is really good and we saw it in
Game two and they just dismantled
Argentina and Messi and that opened up a
lot of eyes and I think a lot of people
said we'll wait a second look at these
guys they they play in you know pareja
Madrid they play for Barcelona they
played for enchilada he's a really good
club that these guys not are just
numbers up or absolute key contributors
for would it be an upset yes would I be
surprised Croatia
refuses yeah I can't be surprised by
Croatia anymore they've won three
straight games to extra time and they
survived survived and survived and in
tournaments like this it's have a hot
keeper survive in advance and have that
will in Croatian man they got a wicked
will to win keep up the enthusiasm there
Rob and I am I'm proud of you you've
done a great job there and I hope you
having fun I'm having a blast I'm
thrilled to talk to you and that just so
you know you were you and several others
over there just a huge part of a huge
part of my life and I forever will thank
you and this is the god-honest truth
they I look back and I I speak so highly
the things I learned from you guys
whether you knew you were educating me
or not you were I was watching you and I
was listening and I was learning and I
really do thank you thank you rob and
good luck this weekend tell the folks we
settle over there will do me good
that's a Rob stone Fox Sports lead
studio host and he was a great kid
though
I mean had that great attitude smile on
his face good-looking
and then he said you know I want to be
on on air and everybody who came into
the mothership 19 20 21 22 college
graduates everybody wanted to be on the
air and then you have to tell them
you're not gonna get on the air here
you're gonna have to leave here and then
if you want to come back then you have a
chance and he did it he did the he put
in the work that you needed to and it's
a great story of course he didn't return
my email
maybe Carissa Thompson gave me a faulty
email address for Rob stone for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]